so farts in space basically in
weightlessness hot air doesn't rise so
the good thing is you probably won't
smell your own fart Because by the time
you've done it it's already been taken
away by the air conditioning system
[Music]
hi I'm Tim Peake a British astronaut and
I flew to the International Space
Station in 2015 2016 and spent six
months living on board I'm here today to
answer the questions in the honesty box
so these have been anonymously sent in
so here goes
first question were you prepared to die
to travel to space Oh that's a good
question
um every astronaut who gets on the
rocket has to consider the uh you know
what could happen the catastrophic
implications of of a rocket destroying
itself or blowing up during launch or
re-entry or space walking or any of the
other hazardous things we do in space so
it's fair to say that any astronaut has
already thought about that and
considered it I've been doing that all
my career as a test pilot I would go on
high risk test sorties where you just
didn't know how the aircraft was going
to perform and um and so I've always
approached these things from a point of
risk mitigation I look up what what I'm
doing what could go wrong and what could
I do about it and then I try and prepare
as best as possible so training training
training make sure that I do everything
possible if anything were to happen
catastrophically
um but yes everybody has to contemplate
that have you ever
um was it have you ever pooed
oh have you ever pooed your spacesuit
okay very sophisticated questions here
have you ever pooed your spacesuit and
what happens to farts in space uh no to
the first and I'll answer the second in
a second uh so really what uh you really
don't want to be considering putting
your space suit that's that's very bad
but let's let's dig into it it's a good
question on launch day
um you're gonna have many many hours in
your spacesuit before you actually get
to the space station so what we actually
start the day off with is an enema uh
and you're actually offered different
types of enema I've got no no idea what
the different I flew from Russia from
Kazakhstan with the Russians and so they
said you can have an American enema or a
Russian enema um didn't know the
difference but I was in Russia so do
what the Russians do so yeah so you
start the day with um a shower where
they scrub you down antibacterial soap
so you don't carry any bacteria or
viruses up to the space station uh you
have an enema to clean you out and that
should stop you from having any desire
uh to go for a poo for at least you know
24 to 48 hours so launch day and the day
after should be absolutely fine
um what we actually wear under our
spacesuits is is what they call a MAG
it's effectively a nappy but NASA liked
to give everything an acronym and
nappy's not very cool for astronauts to
wear so it's a MAG maximum absorbency
garment so it's an adult nappy uh what
happens to farts in space
um so farts in space basically in
weightlessness hot air air doesn't rise
so the good thing is you probably won't
smell your own fart Because by the time
you've done it it's already been taken
away by the air conditioning system and
the air conditioning system on the space
station is pretty good and it's good
it's not there to just stop you from
smelling farts it's there to stop you
from losing Consciousness because if you
didn't have a good air conditioning
system what would happen every time you
breathe out you know we're breathing out
carbon dioxide and so if you didn't have
air moving around and if you're working
for example for a couple of hours at a
laptop in one location this bubble of
carbon dioxide would just build around
you and it wouldn't go anywhere and so
you'd start to get you know CO2
poisoning from your own uh asphyxiation
so a thought would just hang there in
space if it didn't have the good air
conditioning system wow that's a long
answer
to pooing and farting rank the planets
in order from best to worst
okay so let's start with Earth I think
we'd all agree that we're happy
breathing we're happy being alive and
we've got a lovely son that most the
time keeps it as a relatively
comfortable temperature the second
favorite is Mars I love Mars Mars used
to have a liquid ocean uh in about three
billion years ago Earth and Mars were
very very similar it's got the largest
volcano in the solar system it's got the
biggest canyon in the solar system Mars
is geologically fascinating and a
brilliant planet after Mars Saturn's my
favorite I mean it's just the most
beautiful planet in the solar system
with the Rings and it's iconic if you
ask a child draw Planet no chances are
it will be Saturn
um after Saturn I think Jupiter a
stunning planet again a gas giant
biggest planet in the solar system the
Great Red Spot the the hurricane we're
probably going to go to Neptune because
Neptune is right out there on the
furthest extremes of the solar system
but it's a lovely deep blue it's a
beautiful full Bliss it's kind of known
as the the second blue planet in the
solar system After Earth then let's go
to Venus poor old Venus used to be
really really nice I think again a few
billion years ago uh probably a good
place to go on holiday not anymore
runaway greenhouse gas has gone out of
control massive carbon dioxide
atmosphere hottest planet in the solar
system about 460 degrees Celsius on the
surface and uh you know you wouldn't
just wouldn't survive on Venus for very
long at all then let's go to Mercury
um and then all the way back out to the
last planet then um which is Uranus
um yeah I don't think there's much
exciting about Uranus it feels really
bad isn't it to say so but um when
Voyager 2 passed by Uranus
um it was kind of a bit of a bland pale
blue planet wasn't very exciting it was
very cold about minus 240 degrees
Celsius
so that's the order of my planets is
space is space food gross
I suppose it depends on your definition
of gross uh but if you're a foodie then
you're going to be bitterly disappointed
with space food
um there are a couple of things that
they do to space food that makes it
particularly unpalatable first thing is
they remove a lot of the salt content
because Salt's not good for our bone
density loss it does tend to be anything
that could just be rehydrated or like
camping food that are irradiated food
you get in four packets or tins of food
I mean I didn't mind it I'm not a foodie
I'm not food motivated and it never
bothered me space food and you can take
up about 10 of what we call bonus food
which are goodies off the shelf and as
long as it's got a good shelf life and
it passes the space flight site criteria
then you can fly a few off-the-shelf
items up there do you think space travel
is ethical Ah that's a good question do
you think space travel is ethical
um yes I do otherwise I wouldn't be
passionate about what we're doing and
why we're doing it the universe is a a
big place a really big place
um just the Milky Way alone uh I mean
it's a hundred thousand light years side
to side 200 billion stars in the Milky
Way
um we will probably never get close to
exploring even a fraction of the Milky
Way and that's one Galaxy and possibly
two trillion galaxies out there in the
observable universe it's fast it's
absolutely vast the universe the scale
of it is mind-boggling so why should we
restrict ourselves to one small planet I
think space travel is very exciting uh
it offers the potential to learn huge
amounts of information it offers the
potential to discover more uh the
science that we're learning about space
exploration helps us back here on Earth
We're developing vaccines for viruses
drugs for diseases new methods of energy
transformation techniques and carbon
dioxide removal water purification all
these things that are going to help us
solve the problems that we have back
here on Earth so I'm a huge believer in
space exploration in order that we can
use our planet for as long as possible
Elon or Branson or Bezos
um Elon um why because uh and this is
nothing against uh Branson or Bezos as I
mentioned some of the things that are
happening in the commercial sector
suborbital space Transportation Systems
Etc are really interesting uh and could
be very very game changing in the future
but right now what SpaceX are doing is
phenomenal they are I mean to say
they've disrupted the space sector is a
massive understatement it used to cost
about fifty seven thousand dollars on
the space shuttle to launch the space
and now on a falcon 9 a falcon heavy
you'll get that for probably less than
three thousand dollars per kilogram
Starship is going to bring that down
another order of magnitude so uh what
they're doing is making it cheaper and
easier to get into space and they're
offering huge
um cargo payloads hundreds of tons to
low earth orbit that opens the door to
some really exciting Innovative
prospects
um for example getting solo energy from
space is something that would be clean
Limitless energy for all of us back here
on Earth a bit like nuclear fusion but
you can't build a solar farm in space
it's uh prohibitively expensive what
Starship does is it brings it into an
economically viable uh range where
actually building a massive solar farm
in space using Starship is uh you know
you can put the forward the business
case it's economically viable you can
get the payload up there and you can
start thinking about you know
potentially building you know solar
farms in space cleanliness energy these
kinds of things so they are far far more
advanced in terms of what they're doing
for space exploration than Virgin
Galactic or blue origin so Branson and
Bezos what physical changes does your
body undergo in space
lots of physical changes uh the first
five weeks your body's pretty much in
overdrive
um what's happening so first thing you
notice is all the fluid in your legs or
your blood volume basically or the body
fluid that's normally in your legs and
ankles because we're standing and
sitting most of time enough all shifts
up to your chest and face so you become
puffy faced
um your brain doesn't like that gives
you a bit of a headache so you start
losing that blood volume that causes you
to lose weight so you lose about five
kilograms in your first five weeks you
start losing bone density and your
muscles atrophy because you're not using
your bones and muscles as much in space
either cardiovascular system changes
um and even your eyesight changes as
well your immune system becomes more
depleted things like your Airway even
gets in flame so your body's going
through all these changes but actually
your body is doing the right thing our
human body is amazing what it's doing is
it's trying to make you into the perfect
human being for living in space
we try and stop that because we want to
come back to earth and so we exercise
for two hours every day
um to try and keep ourselves fit and
healthy but not fit and healthy for
space fit and healthy for coming back
into a gravity environment so yeah go
into space and coming back is punishing
on the body and that's why we exercise
our astronauts well paid
okay uh astronauts are effectively
government employees as a European Space
Agency astronaut we are employed where
they're about 27 member states that make
up the European Space Agency so it's
like a European governmental
organization so we're paid at the same
kind of salary scale as civil servants
um I mean we're not there with with you
know sports players football stars all
the rest of it it's a it's a decent
salary it's a it's a good level of civil
servant salary what's your favorite
sci-fi film and uh Which is closest to
reality one of my favorite space films
is Apollo 13 but it's not really sci-fi
because it happened and it was very
close to reality and the film was
brilliant and and accurate so sci-fi
film I'll probably say the Martian is my
favorite
um I liked Interstellar as well it was
brilliant film but the Martian um great
fun film Matt Damon's a brilliant actor
a very funny uh it was quite close to
the book Andy Weir's novel
scientifically pretty accurate as well
Andy Weir's novel was very accurate the
Martian gets a little bit Hollywood at
the end flying through space with a
glove ripped but hey you know
Hollywood's there to entertain us it
doesn't always have to be factually
correct should billionaires be allowed
to travel to space should billionaires
be louder as another good question I
think that when we look at space tourism
and what's happening with commercial
suborbital space travel it might be
useful to think back to aviation in the
1920s 1930s those pioneering days of
flying and those first flights across
the Atlantic and that was really only
accessible to really high net worth
individuals who could pay to fly across
the Atlantic in 1930 for example
um now if you said you know what kind of
percentage of the population could
afford to fly across the Atlantic it's
much much greater many people just
consider that that a ordinary holiday
um I think in 100 years time we'll be
thinking of some some form of space
transportation in the same way the cost
of that travel is going to come down and
down and down and it won't just be
billionaires flying to space it will
become a accessible to a much greater
percentage of the population the other
interesting thing is the kind of
suborbital flights that are going on
right now they're just uh launching and
landing at the same location popping up
into space a few minutes of
weightlessness popping back down again
there's no reason why you couldn't
launch in Texas but rather than Landing
in Texas you know Landing in Europe for
example that sub-orbital trajectory is a
point-to-point transportation system
around the world so potentially this
this is actually Paving the way for a
new form of travel that could get you
from London to Sydney in 40 minutes for
example in in 50 years time do you think
anyone has ever had sex in space
good question
um I think on the shuttle I might be
wrong here but I think there may have
been a married couple on the shuttle
that have been in space not to say that
they had sex whilst they're in space but
I think that there has been the
opportunity shall we say
um so do you think anyone's ever had sex
in space not sure
um do I think that people will have sex
in space absolutely space is opening up
at a commercial level we will
potentially have people you know
vacating on orbital hotels in space in
maybe 50 100 years time
um so if it hasn't already happened it
will do
that'll be the 400 kilometer mile high
club what's your favorite alien
character from film or TV for me going
to watch E.T on the big screen was a
huge moment I still remember it my
father took me an amazing film and um I
just think you know E.T is is brilliant
so I'd have to say
um out of all the space films I've
watched E.T wins it do you have a
favorite uh I think a favorite thing to
do in zero gravity
um I think for me in zero gravity
um it's a bit like any sport you get
better and better and better at it the
more that you do it and so after a month
in uh zero gravity your kind of
somersaults and your spins are pretty
good
um after two months you can fly yourself
down the space station without actually
hitting any of the walls and you get
faster and faster it becomes more and
more fun
um but on Friday nights we would tend to
gather together as a crew up in the
Russian segment have a meal together or
bring some of our bonus food and share
it round really nice sociable occasion
talk about the week that we'd had but
the competition on a Friday night was
who could throw an American football the
length of the space station so from
Russian segment all the way down to the
front end of the US segment without it
hitting any of the walls might sound
easy but there's there's a kink there as
you go from the Russian segment to the
American segment it goes kind of off
axis for a bit really hard to do Scott
Kelly had been up there for 8 months
when I go on board the space station and
I think he was the only person I saw
actually do it really cleanly were you
any good at it was I any good at it not
bad after six months uh I think I got it
I did it once um not quite as well as
Scott but at least I got it got it
through the gap
the other thing actually just to follow
up on that question there's a toy box on
board the space station I didn't know
about that until a couple of months into
my mission when I was looking for some
Alka-Seltzer tablets to do a
demonstration of you know when it all
fizzes up in water and I'd run out and
so I asked one of the crewmates and they
said oh go to the toy box there are some
more in there I was like what's the toy
box and they said show me where this bag
was on board the space station and I
looked in there and not only were there
Alka-Seltzer there was a basketball
there was a hoop there were four Nerf
guns in there as well and that was a lot
of fun having a Nerf gun battle on board
the space station
is Pluto a planet
I'd like to say yes but it's sorry it's
not really a planet when you look at the
true definition of a planet
um its size and has it has its clear has
it cleared its own orbital path
um you can't really include Pluto as a
planet so sorry no because Mercury is
way too hot Venus is horrendously hot
and 90 atmospheres pressure and sulfuric
acid rain it melts lead on the surface
right so you're not going there and the
rest of them are made of gas
so you're not going there either so so
Mars is the only place beyond Earth that
we could feasibly ever go a planet